Modern Family it's all coming to an end
but are they ready to go their separate
ways
only kelting I found out guys we are on
set of the final season of Modern Family
and we are are we sad are we happy I'm
sad and we're really sad
[Music]
has it sunk in that we're at the end ah
I don't think so I don't know if it will
hit me until maybe the wrap party if
they show like a sappy video how do you
say goodbye after 11 seasons more than
240 episodes and 5 et CET Bizet's leave
a clip the full et cetera for the show
even aired what oh my gosh was that hair
tie it was really awesome like even my
whole family was freaking out like oh my
god oh my god that's crazy that's Rico
looks adorable
Nolan looks cute I am you know this is a
phase would there be a spinoff would you
pop in like glory I'll just like come
for the weekend oh of course if they
need ok court I don't want more than
family to it I want it to be like Law &
Order what are you gonna steal from set
to keep as a memento um that's stupid
ugly vase it is right there right there
yeah ok that one because I'm in like all
my scenes are usually here yeah by this
table so that's like my thing
[Music]